you actually
been in the studio with dre more than
once i've been to dr dre's house
you've been to his house into his house
we just got a thousand pair of white air
force ones
but like i went on a tour in dr dre
house he like
showing you like the long guy swimming
pool like his
gym like he hitting the speed bag and
[ __ ] i heard his studio's insane at his
house
yeah yeah yeah um i was crazy yeah my my
first time
i went to the uh to the studio in this
crib
so when i posted pictures in the studio
with dre i was i was at his house
that's fire so how was like how was that
man like and and
crazy what was the conversations like
with jay did you play him any music
yeah i did i played the music i
definitely did
but [ __ ] man the conversation was super
crazy because i'm like man i got
my daughter was on the way and i was
getting dad advice from dr dre and [ __ ]
like that and that she was just like
damn
that's big nah wow um but um
another pinch me moment hell yeah not
yet i played on music but it's crazy
because like when we got in there like
he was in there dlc like um fred wreck
was there like
it was like some real his team yeah
there was some real [ __ ] going on
um so uh fuzzy was like um
you know you want to want to play some
records and he was like yeah he kept
saying like the mic is hot
because they was they was writing mm-hmm
so he was saying like
basically he wasn't about to let me
press play until you know he did
something yeah
i want to see what he could do he just
kept saying that so um i watched him um
he went up to the boot i mean he went up
to the mic and
he was laying just um
like melody i guess you would say right
so he was
he was mumbling and there was like
halfway words there
so what i did was like fuzzy kept saying
like you ready you ready
so i sat in the back um and i put words
to them so i went up to
when i when i finally walked up to the
mic it was
it was like eight bars because i had
filled in everything everything
i did oh so it was it was like
instant respect that's fire and also the
fact that like
no one's ever gonna hear what you did
because because
because we've been waiting for the detox
since i was i wasn't old enough to drink